hi reject nation Greg Alva here I'm John
7 in the morning for us but it's time to
get spooked out right the new Halloween
trailer is here highly anticipated I
heard this too great at CinemaCon before
we go into this patron today shout out
for a Natalie Doran Natalie Doran art Oh
a rich lady she is actually coming to
America next week she's gonna be going
on a crazy trip into Florida she's gonna
get so drunk so wasted she's gonna have
so many regrets with so many men and
maybe women too that's the American
lifestyle combined with the Irish
lifestyle and also Halloween is her
favorite horror franchise we had a long
discussion about it last time we did a
Google hangout with her Natalie we love
you hopefully you enjoyed this trailer
oh yeah anyway let's see what all the
Hubble Louvre is about let's do it wait
hmm testing one two three we're on we're
here to investigate the patient that
killed three innocent teenagers on
Halloween in 1978 you still shot by a
psychiatrist and taken into custody that
night interesting last 40 years in
captivity good it's smart hello Michael
[Music]
something you might like to see
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
I mean a grandmother is Laurie Strode
she was almost murdered wasn't it her
brother converted all those babysitters
yeah it was not her brother that's what
many people made up did you do that for
so I can kill him
what bus crash Michael escaped
excuse me somebody's in here
[Music]
oh hey wait for this night he's waiting
for me
I'm waited from who
this looks great yeah
[Music]
like
[Music]
[Laughter]
we gotta explain some of like the
reaction that we were having
conversation last night about how like
how are they gonna market this properly
because this is supposed to be the
direct sequel after Halloween one so
that are ignoring all the Halloween
movies after Halloween part one which I
was like couldn't that confuse an
audience and I feel like there might be
some people who watch this still it will
be confused like we saw ty Rhodes video
even to that trailer teaser she survived
if you don't follow movie news you might
not understand this at all especially if
you see a Halloween resurrection but
they were doing stuff to debunk the
other ones in this trailer to me to try
to make it less confusing yeah so I like
the plot set up Michael Myers has been
an asylum for 40 years now he never got
out he never he never broke out of there
I thought that was a clever spin to do
on it to make it establish like oh so
none of that actually happened and the
other part too is they took away the
whole Laurie Strode and Michael Myers
yeah her brother that gets revealed that
the original Halloween two they're kind
of showing stuff here to help the
audience understand they're erasing or
ignoring a lot of that and that's why I
was like oh smart clever yeah yeah I
mean the just the production values on
this thing I mean this the Tony even
looks like a totally different kind of
film
he's really long yeah writing steady
shots and whatnot like that whole
sanitary I'm seeing is where the dogs
are freaking out everybody's just
standing around and it's really wide and
like they're really building up yeah man
that is Michael Myers like this looks
really intense actually I love the
approach they're doing with Laurie
Strode as this woman who's been just
like kinda gone a little crazy has been
preparing her survivor yeah she's just
been like
ready for him to come back yeah he is
like the boogey man who has really
traumatized her I just spent 40 years
preparing for the night Michael Myers
comes back well yeah and to see him also
just walking around in the neighborhood
on Halloween gave me chills because that
really did feel like you know you're
really bringing it full circle now like
a Halloween night forty years later for
this final showdown even if you don't
get it from the outset I feel like this
trailer does a good job in addressing
what the concerns might be and just
really leading with like here's the tone
we're going for it yeah I didn't expect
this
it feels twisted but it doesn't feel
like aggressively twisted yeah it feels
yeah
twisted maybe a bit more aggressive than
the original updated for now but not it
feels akin to the yeah yeah because
going back to Laurie Strode in the first
one you know Laurie has no idea who
Michael Myers is all this is all just
kind of random but she has a light in
here she says she's been praying so she
can so she can kill it so this makes it
a very personal conflict for so I like
that this is Laurie Strode versus
Michael Myers and certain a certain
retrospect the closer yeah after so many
years of what must be trauma I feel like
the fun Halloween thrills will probably
come in the area of you know they
establish that Laurie has this
granddaughter here and it looks like
that's where like the foot Halloween
what we know slasher thrills will
probably come around that arena with the
teenagers and whatever one thing I'm
hoping for after looking at this trailer
is that this film sticks with some type
of theme of her dealing with trauma
Laurie Strode
because I kind of feel like with the
granddaughter stuff and the tea and her
babysitting and then Michael Myers being
in the home and attacking that's very
Halloween desk you know it's really
repetitive so that could either go down
to ways like yeah we've seen that in
Halloween before that's kind of
repetitive expect that or it can go
along with the themes of trauma
repeating itself in the present day for
Laurie Strode oh yeah that's a
granddaughter Laura's been prepared for
this there's a way to get away with that
in a clever way yeah well I think this
does deliver on there the goal of going
back to like the very very basics of
what makes Halloween scary by kind of
removing the brother-sister element
because yeah it really does give you
that I don't know why he just wants to
kill me like terror of the unknown there
is a seventies kind of quality about
this and also this sort of follow-up
like what the trauma of that original
experience does to you is kind of echoed
in his Halloween too but this feels like
it has its own thing going on I think
that's really cool to just to know who's
involved because like David Gordon Green
was supposed to do Suspiria and then
that kind of fell through I feel like
that's gonna be this year's it to see
what his vision is gonna be for this and
also remembering that Danny McBride
co-wrote this there seems to be an
energy and a pacing about it that I
don't know that the word is fun but
there's like an enthusiasm behind the
behind of filmmaking yeah yeah without
being too like overtly like haha ya know
yeah it seems like whoever's making this
is like really going for it alright guys
well are you satisfied with a new
Halloween trailer do you think this will
you know course-correct after like stand
on this you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
Belko subscribe buttons are kind of
broken and you can check us out on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A zyk video coverage would love
to have you become a patron jek today